رايتان حمراء لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
علمنا ووطننا واحد
أنا أقول لك أكثر اثنين اثنين الأساسية اثنين
لدينا خط أحمر وعلمنا و
وطننا
لكنهم
نظام الرجل الواحد
أعرف بالضبط ما يفعلونه
انظروا
انظروا يا شباب، استمعوا بعناية هنا.
خطفوا قبر سليمان شاه
قبر سليمان شاه
هذا
تقع داخل حدود سوريا
قبر سليمان شاه
قام عشرة آلاف شخص ببناء هذا القبر
فدان من الأراضي
وفروا من التنظيم الإرهابي
لقد أنزلوا علمنا
وغادروا وطنهم
أولئك الذين يفعلون ذلك لن يكونوا قوميين أبدًا
أولئك الذين يفعلون هذا لا يمكن أن يكونوا كذلك أبدًا
لا يمكن أن يكونوا وطنيين
لدي وعد لهذه الأمة
الله يرزقها بأصواتكم
سترون عندما نصل إلى السلطة
قبر سليمان شاه إلى أرض الوطن
سوف نستعيد علمنا
سوف نزرعها هناك